اسمح لي قبل ان ادخل في هذا الموضوع
اعود كنت معك في حلقه سابقه نتكلم في
تدوين السنه نعم واحب ان ننبه الامرين
ربما الوقت لم يسعفني
نحن نتمنى او نرجو من المملكه وهي دوله
محافظه على الاسلام والدين كما ان مصر
دوله محافظه على الاسلام والدين ان نصنع
مشروعا في الاحاديث في السنه النبويه كل
حديث يخالف القران الكريم ولا يمكن الجمع
كل حديث يخالف العقل نطرحه مؤقتا
نستبعده مؤقتا حتى نخفف الكم الهائل من
الاحاديث التي تصنع المشكلات بين القران
وبين السنه الامر الثاني من 50 سنه الشيخ
محمد الغزالي رحمه الله نبا في كثير من
كتبه على قضيه مهمه جدا في السنه وهي قضيه
اسباب ورود الحديث في علوم القران هناك
اسباب النزول في السنه هناك اسباب ورود
الحديث في مؤلفات قليله لان هناك الكثير
من الاحاديث النبويه قيلت في مناسبات
معينه يعني النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام لما
قال امرت ان اقاتل الناس لا يمكن ان نحمل
كلمه الناس على عمومها لان عندنا ايات
قرانيه وقاتل في سبيل الله الذين
يقاتلونكم ولا تعتدوا انما المناسبات تقول
بان امرت ان يقاتل الناس المشركين الذين
كانوا يرفعون عليه السلاح احنا مش محدده
ناس محددين لا نعرفه من سبب النزول فلو
عملنا دراسه ايضا تتبناها المملكه باننا
نحصر الاحاديث واسباب الورود التي وردت
فيها والظروف الاجتماعيه التي وردت فيها
والظروف التاريخيه التي وردت فيها اعتقد
اننا سنقول الكثير من الاشكلات اعود الى
سؤالك المهم جدا
ايضا في تجربتي وانا اعميد دراسات عليا
سابق واشرفت على الاف من الرسائل العلميه
في الازهر وخارج الازهر ايضا المشكله
الاساسيه في التعليم في تنشئه الطالب
العلماء الاقدمون يقولون العالم لابد ان
يقوم بواجب الوقت يعني ايه يعني الدراسات
الجامعيه عندما تصنع رسائل علميه ماجستير
دكتوراه لازم هذه الرسائل العلميه تخدم
المجتمع تحل قضايا المجتمع لكن معظم
الرسائل العلميه في وادي والمجتمع في وادي
اخر يعني انت تجد مثلا ان طالبا وكثير
يبحث عن مخطوطات في التفسير في الحديث في
اصول الفقه قديمه ليس فيها جديد ثم ياتي
ويحققوها ويخرجها ويطبعه وتزيد كتب الاصول
كتبا وتزيد كتب الحديث كتبا كتب التفسير
طب ما الجديد انا اقول نبحث عن رسائل
علميه تخاطب المجتمع
تخاطب حياه الناس العلماء يقولون من هو
المجتهد يقول للمجتهد هو الذي يدرك النص
الشرعي بعدين قالو يدرك الواقع المعيش
وبعدين هل هو كيف ينزل النص على الواقع
يعني الواقع متغير لذلك النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام قال الحلال ما حل الله في كتابه
والحرام ما حرم الله في كتابه قال وما سكت
عنه فوعف فاقبلوا من الله عافيتك فعندنا
دائره واسعه في الاسلام جدا هي دائره
العفو هي دائره المسكوت عنه وهي الدائره
الاكبر نعمل فيها ايه الدائره دي يقولون
ياتي المجتهدون المبدعون المفكرون اللي
المفترض ان طلاب الدكتوراه والماجستير
واساتذه الجامعه يكونوا على هذا القدر من
الفكر يعمله ايه قال يملاوا هذه المنطقه
الفارغه بما يحقق مصادر
الدراسات
كلها تقليديه كما قلت لك قسم كبير جدا من
الرسائل العلميه يتحدث في مخطوطات قديمه
قسم اخر السطحي
وضعف الضعف العلمي وضعف الالات عند كثير
من الطلاب وعند بعض المشرفين فان الطالب
يكتب اي كتابه سطحيه وانت تتعجب من شيء
غريب جدا في العالم العربي انا لا يخص
جامعه بعنا تجد ان كل الرسائل امتياز مع
التوصيه بالطبع امتياز يا اخواننا هل
الطلاب جميعا عقولهم واحده هل الموضوعات
كلها في العمق واحده يعني الجامعات صنعت
في عندها امتياز عندها جيد جدا عندها جيد
جدا
يعني لكن كل الرسائل امتياز